ce qui s'est passé dans ce désert a
défini le fait de quitter notre pays
les maisons de nos pères pour quoi
pour le royaume de Dieu, je voulais
créer une histoire d'horreur archétypale de la Nouvelle-Angleterre
sur des travaux logiques pour avoir
quelque chose qui ressemblerait à un cauchemar
du passé si vous  pourrait télécharger un
cauchemar d'essence pure dans le cerveau du public
c'est ce que j'espérais que les gens
pourraient expérimenter il y avait vraiment de l'
obscurité et du danger dans ce que le début
moderne qui était le bien
J'espère que le public repartira avec des
questions ces vieux contes de fées et
contes folkloriques ils étaient riches  avec mystère et
énigme et épopée oh mon seigneur je commence maintenant
à la maison et je laisse mon
péché c'est treuil parce que ce
repentant tâtonnant Oh Shelby du mal je vais
changer l'étude physique attendre
et tourner le cercle
hé avoué que j'ai vécu dans le péché  est EV
se forme et du feu L durable montrez-moi le
manquer
montrez-moi que la vie comme Philips si vous
êtes avec kata ce désert ne
consommera pas qui fait partie d'un  Tout mon
premier cauchemar est le 17e siècle,
le plus pur dans lequel elle est beaucoup
plus primitive et beaucoup plus effrayante que nous
ne l'aurions jamais imaginé, rien de tout
cela pour moi est crucial pour que le
monde entier soit aussi précis que possible jusqu'au
17e  siècle parce que nous avions vraiment besoin de
croire en ce monde et d'être super
ancrés pour pouvoir croire en
ce que ces gens ont fait
parce que cette famille le cadre est un
personnage cela a rendu tout cela très réel ce n'est
pas comme un conte de fées qui  elle est
effrayante, le film devait être sombre,
le DP a magnifiquement conçu la
lumière naturelle pour recréer cette idée authentique
de ce que serait la Nouvelle-Angleterre du 17ème siècle,
nous devions tout faire car
il n'y avait aucun moyen de faire semblant,
c'était la barre haute que nous avons tous  besoin d'
aller pour naviguer qui peut être réel
vous